what's going on reject nation g j here
we are gonna watch fast and furious nine
two and a half hours we're gonna go
watch goodness
another fast furious video at the man's
chinese theater
and uh yeah it's gonna pop on here real
quick and then right when we're done
watching the movie we'll come back out
here
and let you guys know what our honest
thoughts are about the movie
i'm looking forward to it let's see what
goes on you're excited john justice for
hans justice
so we just got done with fast and
furious nine i got a bit of a headache
uh a lot there's a lot of crashing a lot
of sounds
a lot of noises right here on hollywood
boulevard a lot of people yelling a lot
of people walking by but john what do
you think you can go
first buddy uh i had a blast in the way
that you have a blast with one of these
hey jaby kawaii is here in the video
this makes sense with john cena
being the brother absolutely i saw
ourselves on screen
the whole time we were watching it yeah
it's like man so many times jeffy cohen
i've been in this position
oh yeah but you know what this movie
taught me that it's not about being
stronger
it's about being the bigger man yeah
absolutely and that's not a spoiler
so before this movie started uh the the
person outside
said look we can't do the reviews just
yet you got to be careful what you say
because there's so much
that there's still left to spoil about
the movie and i
i gotta be honest with you i don't know
what the hell she was talking about
yeah i mean if you know fast and furious
you probably know what you're getting
into what to
expect and where the story will probably
go
once you've seen sailors at least it's
just as predictable as we probably said
in all the videos
i was like nothing surprising about this
movie i'll still say like the action i
still thought was very exciting and
exhilarating there were a couple of
times you got
like throughout the movie there was a
few times where he got a lot of whoos
from me
uh in particular especially when he did
do the space sequence
as shown in the trailer not spoiling it
everything where you got
it mass marketing for this film yeah
like that was exciting
and there were times in the finale like
at one point i looked at him like how
the hell did they do that
that looks really impressive yeah there
are some amazing practical stunts
as ridiculous as this movie gets and as
much as the movie comments on its own
ridiculousness there are some amazing
car
stunts there's a much yeah at one point
they're literally just
throwing cars in another car and it it's
kind of magical in a really destructive
way yeah
like it's literally the action they
still manage to top themselves every
film series
i think the biggest issue i got with
this movie is kind of what i was
starting to feel with fate of the
furious
see this is from director justin lin who
did like the fourth fast and furious and
the fifth and sixth one
if you go to the fourth one that's when
it was still like
incredibly soap-opery and then by the
time we got to fast five and furious six
it started becoming more self-aware what
they were doing when there wasn't action
scenes going on it started becoming very
much like we know that this is uh
that the drama is not really like
yeah the drama is like cheesy and
ridiculous like they they're aware of
that
and then in this installment i don't
know it's because just one step away for
a couple movies i feel like justin lin
completely lost sight
of the self-awareness with the drama in
between
like there's a packed house when we saw
it and
people were just dying of laughter
throughout our lap so much of this movie
at scenes you're not suppo you're so
obviously not supposed to be laughing at
this
almost any time you had a close-up on
john cena i just felt so sorry for the
guy because people just started laughing
uh yeah yeah he's got a lot of
smoldering in this movie a lot of people
standing there giving intense looks
oh character what did
it was silly but it was fun don't
think about things don't ask questions i
asked questions and i was like why am i
asking questions
don't do that our cameraman was next to
me asking questions the whole movie
to remind him that it's not that kind of
move let's just have everyone come in
here one at a time yeah
courtney come in here come here what do
you think what did you think courtney
uh i had a great time it was a lot of
fun didn't really make a whole lot of
sense in certain sections
but it was a great ride i agree with
achara don't think
just go don't think shabby
feels like a finger pointing away to the
moon
literally what did you think what's your
quick thoughts on this
it was a fun movie uh you know if you
like the other the last one you'll like
this one too
but um i i don't know it doesn't measure
up to fast five that's my favorite
but it was fun it was a fun movie
there's definitely moments where you're
like
in a fast and furious movie that makes
sense yeah that's about that
josh get over here hobbs and shaw throw
that in the trash
come back to the festive beers franchise
because i feel like they're really
missing
the team the team in this one is kind of
just all over the place uh some of the
people from the past
i missed the old school team so for me
it's a fast and furious movie
yeah that's all it is on the car ride
you asked me like do you care that
dwayne johnson and just take them around
here and i'm like not really
and then i didn't realize how much of a
presence they really brought until
watching this room like
this movie gets really dragged down it
completely keeps drifting by
it's it's like drama that is so tokyo
that does not hit you in the fields
where you just laugh it at the whole
yeah it almost needs as much as it is
the vin diesel and company franchise it
almost needs dwayne johnson to bring his
brand of
self-aware cheekiness to hold the world
together the more crazy they go
the more ridiculous they get the further
into space we will inevitably go
like in between the action scenes it's
not fun and it's only fun in between the
action scenes when it's not intending to
be fun
there's a comedy that doesn't always
land and there's unintentional comedy
that always like yeah that's a great way
to play a very strange
way to have the humor unintentional
comedy
kind of peaked attended around eight and
seven i would say at times
but vin diesel is like i'm going for the
oscars yeah i know he's like what is he
people with an ass
people he thinks people were here for
the drama and
and speaking of the drama i mean there
is a pretty heavy
uh backstory portion of this and
in a lot of ways i thought they cast
better actors to beat the younger
versions of dominance
yeah i thought they were actually good
actors so i was like you get these
flashbacks in here that are just insane
i'll give them some credit for not
de-aging yes like yeah they got actual
actors
actual should actually i'm gonna hunt my
way out of here i'll be back in the
sequel
but i was standing through all those uh
flashbacks going man it's a shame we'll
never get to see vin diesel emote this
much
all right let's swap out let's get your
opinion aaron let's get your opinion
been there
well i don't really watch these fast and
furious movies i'm not a marvel guy
myself
but um it's not great um i had a lot of
questions
a lot of weird wild [ __ ] happened and
you know
uh i'm cool i don't i don't know if i
ever need to see these again
come at me internet fight me um
say that it's not good it's fun
it's fast it's furious it's ridiculous
we have
caricatures of black people it's great
come on tyreese come on
listen his was a he was the person who
was supposed to have the commentary
about
what everybody says when they go and
watch it fast and furious now
or novel tv all the things
but they don't even fully commit to the
commentary they're
the self-awareness of the madness the
commentary that like
everything in the
[Laughter]
i don't even know if i'm in frame right
now all right guys let's get a group
shot yeah group shot everybody no john
john you got to be in the shot with us
all right all right group shot let's see
if we can do this we're doing family
like
best family we did it we courtney's the
only one
this is the people in this room is that
it do you think that angle is good do
you think we got the thumbnail
we probably got the big deal i think we
got the thumbnail for some odd reasons
and he's jealous focus on me so
definitely not me all right
we did it the review's done i give it a
five out of
some whatever doesn't [ __ ] matter if
it's if you like pacifiers you'll like
it